في الطرقات والمزارع وتحت الانقاض ايضا
يبحث هؤلاء عن مصادر موت اخفتها ميليشيات
الحوث تحت التراب تتربص بحياه المدنيين
الابرياء جدد متواصل اذا تبذله الفرق
الهندسيه لمشروع مسام السعودي لتطهير
الاراضي اليمنيه من الالغام الحوثيه فهذه
المدرسه الواقعه غربه عز حولت عبوات الحوت
الناسفه جزءا منها الى ركام واليوم تفتح
ابوابها من جديد بامان لاستقبال مئات
الطلبه بعد ان نزعت منها فرق مشروع مسام
اكثر من 60 لغما وقذيفه غير متفجره من
مخلفات حرب
الحوثين بعد الحمد لله
شكرا لفريق الالغام وفريق مسام
بعض الالغام نحن فرحين عادات المدرسه
المدارس الملوثه في تعز من وثقنها 17
مدرسه ملوثه بالالغام والعبوات الناسفه
وهناك اكثر من هذا العدد في مناطق التماس
ومناطق خط النا لما نصلي اليها ومشروع
مسام سيكون له خطه شامله في محافظه تعز
للتدخل الايجابي في تطهير هذه المدارس
وكذلك رفع الالقاب الذي يمهد لاعاده
الاعمار في هذه المدارس
بالاليات هذه اذا وخلال اشهر فقط مكنت
الفرق الهندسيه لمشروع مسافه التابع لمركز
الملك سلمان الاف الطلبه من العوده الى
مدارسهم في تعز حيث تم تطهير 27 مدرسه
اساسيه في انحاء المحافظه اضافه الى تطهير
احياء سكنيه ومزارع وممرات في المدينه
والريف الاخوه في فريق مسام مشكورين
بيئه تعليميه امنه لهذه المدرسه وايجاد
مجتمع امن للنطاق الجغرافي المحيط بهذه
المدرسه فقاموا باعاده برفع الركام مخلفات
البناء التي انفجرت في هذا المكان وكما
قاموا بنزع الغام ونزع العبوات الناسفه
التي كانت تمثل خطر على ابناءنا الطلاب
وعلى المواطنين
ومنذ انطلاق المشروع منتصف عام 2018 تمكنت
الفرق التابعه له من نزع وتدمير اكثر من
390 الف رغم وعبوه ناسفه وقذائف غير
متفجره كانت قد زرعتها الميليشيات في
مناطق متفرقه في اليمن هائل سعيد العربيه
تعز